funny thing is when I talked to Chinese
leaders they they actually now want
Trump to win a second term why no
shocking right it's shocking under Trump
they see that the relations between the
US and core allies is so mistrusted that
that the Chinese have more opportunity
to make up ground in other places which
they fear they wouldn't be able to do as
effectively under by internet that
really says something welcome back to
Yankee I'm Zack Raman English campaign
manager from our 2020 run today we've
got another bonus episode for you that
answers this question what is going on
in the world but seriously coronavirus
is a global pandemic and we're all
feeling the effects at home but there's
a real question and what this has done
in terms of changing the rest of the
world and where we the United States
stand in comparison so in this episode
we bring in the one and only Ian Bremmer
who's a foreign policy genius and expert
president of the Eurasia Group and g0
media and him an angel talk about the
future of the world and I mean the
actual world not just our own little
worlds we live in right now on a
personal level I've always really hated
foreign policy and never understood it
and most people I find while they say
they care they they generally don't but
these guys getting some really crazy
nerdy stuff which I found fascinating
they talk about why China or how China
actually wants trump to win because they
love that Europe hates us they talk
about how surveillance States I'm able
to respond faster to co vid and why our
distrust in the United States of our
government is actually hurting our
recovery right now and the last thing to
talk about something called
geoengineering which is when you start
making man-made efforts to combat
climate change so buckle up this bonus
episode is about the new world we are
all gonna start living in I feel like
the US right now is in more of a
position to need help then offer it you
know it seems like we still have massive
shortages of testing and PPE yeah do you
think that China
as an opportunity to genuinely fill that
vacuum you know I think that the United
States if we wanted to do more we
certainly could you're right Andrew that
today we we lack tests but in six months
time twelve months time that this debate
is not going to be about medical supply
chain it's going to be about getting the
global economy back moving and a whole
bunch of developing countries are gonna
desperately need aid and we've got the
deep pockets so there will be a question
of the IMF the World Bank others are the
Americans gonna step up with our allies
because the Chinese are not gonna do
much there's still a comparatively poor
country where I think the Chinese have a
real advantage is the fact that you and
I are sitting here talking about this in
the teeth of this crisis
and the Chinese economy has already
restarted because they have a
surveillance state they have a
technologically empowered authoritarian
system which has allowed them to
quarantine people to get a hundred
percent compliance and to control the
rebuilding of their supply chain getting
it up and running when the Americans and
the Europeans are still shut down and
deeply politically conflicted about how
and when we will restart it and I think
that that ability of the Chinese to show
countries maybe some countries that
don't care quite as much about democracy
but really want to get their economies
going hey look at what we're doing with
technology look at what we're doing with
surveillance look what we're doing with
data wouldn't you like to have your
economy rebuilt like that and by the way
that'll also give you the government a
lot more control of your population
they'll be much more quiescent they'll
be much more loyal I worry that there
are countries out there in Southeast
Asia in sub-saharan Africa in East and
southern Europe even in Latin America
that will find that model more appealing
America won't Japan won't Germany won't
but it's getting harder when the average
American doesn't believe in the American
dream and the average Chinese does
believe in the Chinese dream which is
what she's in paying use
right when he tries to really gain
patriotism in China we've got a problem
in convincing others around the world
that you should follow us I had family
members who arrived in China and they
were greeted at the airport and then
escorted to their apartment for
quarantine
there was a monitor put on their
apartment to let anyone know if someone
left and then a government worker showed
up there every day to take their
temperature and I tweeted this just
being like hey this is what's happening
in China and people saw then were like
wow that would never be possible the
United States of America on multiple
levels like that there is such a premium
on our individual liberty and the
exporting of authoritarianism and
surveillance technology it's a very dark
vision but I a hundred percent agree
it's happening like it's going to happen
it's like the exportation of dystopia
yeah I mean you and I probably saw the
same black mayor episodes so I mean yeah
sure I watch my mirror as like you know
homework due diligence that yeah like
where are we going in three years what's
happening in China in two weeks that's
basically black mayor one of my favorite
quotes it comes from William Gibson and
it says the future is already here it's
just not evenly distributed and so a lot
of what we are seeing in China right now
could be coming to a theater near us
real soon and I agree that the US
government would have a hard time
implementing all of that but you know
Facebook is implementing a lot of it
without it being policy we're just
willingly giving them all of our data
because it's a quote unquote free
service and when Apple and Google
suddenly say they're gonna work together
for geolocation and contact tracing
because without it we can't restart our
economy and I think there are a lot of
Americans who would be very willing to
say well I want control of my data but
if that's the only way I can get back to
work
I think a lot of people gonna take that
you know my mom well you know me I grew
up in the projects my mom was not a
capitalist
because she didn't have capital she
would have been a capitalist if she had
capital but she didn't believe in that
system because her view was with you
know capitalist are just people that try
to screw me and my family for their own
benefit and so this idea that somehow
Americans would never tolerate X Y or Z
I think starts to change when Americans
get pissed off that their system isn't
providing for them and Americans would
never vote for a socialist president
except a lot of Americans now are such
more supportive of things that feel like
socialism in the United States because
they think capitalism doesn't work for
them so I think representative democracy
and capitalism as we have lived it in
the last 40 years your in my lifetime
Andrew do not appear to be working for
the majority of the American population
and that that I think will lead us to
change what we are and are not prepared
to tolerate from our leaders you mean my
quote unquote socialist ideas like
giving everyone 1,200 bucks another
example I mean I've heard of that as an
idea right yeah yeah there was someone
who ran around the country talking about
that a lot Wow and now it's like and now
other countries are actually doing it
which is the funny thing they should be
giving you a small royalty you wouldn't
need much well you know I'll just settle
for us doing it here poor countries do
it some that Trump put his name on that
first check did that annoy you
well what annoyed me about it was that
he actually delayed the checks as a
result you know it's like I don't really
care whose names on a thing but if
you're in a delay payment just to get
your name on it that's true that's
unconscionable it has to not take any
extra time you know it's like I mean if
I'm an American on the other end I just
like I just want my [ __ ] money it's
like I don't really care whose names on
the [ __ ] check kept me the money
[Music]
it is an unprecedented time I agree with
you that many Americans would be willing
to share data points if it meant
reopening or being safer like saving
lives you know we need that and I mean
that's how South Korea was as successful
as they were very early they had
effective contact tracing for every
single case they were enormous ly
aggressive about it was quite intrusive
it would have felt uncomfortable doing
that in the United States but I you know
what feels a lot more uncomfortable
being stuck in our [ __ ] houses and
people dying I'm dying and unemployment
going up and all this other [ __ ] I mean
I just I just think that life is not
happy for a lot of Americans right now
yeah it's terrible it's devastating you
know what's funny and I was in Iowa
campaigning still and some reporters
from Bloomberg asked asked me about
coronavirus and this is before it become
really anything here in the US and I
said I was like look we should be
freaking tracking anyone who lands from
affected areas and just like follow them
around and just make sure that nothing's
going on with them for the two weeks
until you see whether they're they're
symptomatic and then the Bloomberg
reporter has looked at me were like
follow around there's such like a
mistrust of government here in the US I
think that many Americans would be more
open just to giving their data to
Facebook and being like this book will
keep track of this then giving it to the
government yeah I mean that that's like
that mistrust is making it harder for us
to get a lot of things done what one
thing I'd really I'm surprised we're not
talking more about I don't mean you and
me but generally is we need everyone to
wear and 95 masks and you can't say that
right now
because we don't have enough for medical
personnel and so you don't want to have
a run on them but every serious
epidemiologist I talked to tells me that
if citizens are engaged in social
distancing and all wearing and 95s or
Kant or whatever the Chinese version of
the n95 is which is just as good
apparently
yeah but actually you would bring the
curve down functionally to a tiny
fraction of what it now is and that
would allow us to get the economy back
up and running and in the previous stage
that's gonna be perhaps the biggest
single piece of allowing everyday
Americans to get back to work and I
agree with you that I think the reason
why they're not saying everyone should
wear an n95 is because we don't want to
have a run on it where health care
providers don't have access to it but I
also agree with you that's where we
should head as quickly as possible like
as soon as we get the supply yeah but
again we're not moving anywhere close to
fast enough in that direction where we
know you put that order the defense
order in for more ventilators
ventilators are hard as Trump keeps
saying and 95 masks are actually not
that hard that this is something that
you know three months into the crisis
the world's only superpower should be
able to do and that angers me you know
I'm just I understand that China lied to
us they covered it up but they covered
it up to everyone including their own
people so I mean we found out about what
was going on in China at the same time
that Singapore did that South Korea did
that Germany did the Taiwan did that
Canada did that New Zealand did how is
it remotely possible that we are not
outperforming those countries given all
of the extraordinary science and tech
and resources and private sector
companies that we have in this country
that just it's that that level of that
lack of accountability just really
really I mean I we know that Trump has
no empathy we know he's not fit to be
President but but the complete lack of
accountability and responsibility under
his leadership and this in this crisis
is just unacceptable I could not agree
more it's disgusting it's reprehensible
and I'm so pissed off about it just the
value destruction and like lives lost
and everything else that could have been
averted if you'd had anywhere near
competent leadership and execution and
if anything is right in the world it's
going to be like the end of Trump's
presidency right you know it's like the
fact that we're we're all in this boat
you know we ought to be able to vote him
out
right now we're in crisis mode so we're
all saying like yeah let's let's come
together and let's help each other in
the rest of it but if there if there is
like an inspection of just the depth of
our government's failures it's going to
be beyond infuriating for many many of
us yeah yeah it is people are gonna get
more sick more gonna die more economic
impact as because we are not coordinated
because states are pitting against each
other and pitting against the federal
government as opposed to the country all
rowing together the state versus state
bidding wars I'm hearing about like the
the fact that FEMA is like appropriating
supply and like out beating everyone for
a national stockpile yeah but it's it's
still a total [ __ ] show mess no like
when I talk to folks because what we're
involved with trying to help get PP into
people's hands we've been doing economic
relief and when I talked to people at
the hospital level like there's still
areas that are completely
under-resourced that if you had any kind
of rational national leadership you'd be
like you know what rural Mississippi is
gonna be a real problem like who is yeah
that's gonna be a real problem you know
and those communities predominantly
black you know low levels of health care
infrastructure or high levels of
pre-existing conditions it's going to be
very very difficult for us to get our
arms around this virus if it's just
ravaging poor black communities and we
just have nowhere near the levels of
resources to help them because they're
getting stockpiled in some richer state
I mean even under Obama inequality grew
under eight years of Obama in the United
States because this is so endemic it's
so structural and and of crisis of this
size when stimulus is massively
politicized and you get it if you're
close to the people that are making the
decisions we know that's the way it work
inequality is going to be driven well
beyond pre depression levels in the
United States and and we're gonna have
to ask ourselves some very uncomfortable
questions about whether we really live
in a representative democracy you know
the things I was worried
are now at our doorstep I mean it's it's
incredible the accelerated timeframe
[Music]
let's say that you know I'm Joe Biden
and it's 2021 like what does the world
look like if the United States does what
it's doing now or does very little
internationally and then what could the
world look like if we were to take a set
of affirmative steps the world looks
more anarchic human rights matter less
China grabs a larger chunk of some
really poor countries there's less
coordination in responding to big global
challenges not just like the pandemic
but climate AI FX biotech I mean the big
challenges that are coming down the pike
end up getting resolved differently by
different countries and
lowest-common-denominator applies so
rogue states and individuals become more
important and there's a lot more danger
in the world and the United States
becomes just another but really powerful
but just another state
there's nothing exceptional about it and
I think what the US needs to do as a
country that still is the most powerful
in the world has the world's largest
energy production food production most
powerful private sector corporations
entrepreneurship and the reserve
currency is that we need to actually
spend that both more at home first
because if you don't take a care of the
average American then the rest will go
away but you also need to really invest
in trusted relationships with allies
Trump's biggest mistake in my view and
foreign policy is that he actually
thinks that a strong Europe is bad for
America he supported brexit he supports
you know the Italians and others that
are trying you're skeptic Slyke or bonds
and hungry that's a disaster when you're
fighting against China that has an
authoritarian state capitalist system
you need the strongest democracies that
share
values as you possibly can have and we
are not only indifferent to that we're
actively eroding it that's a horrible
thing think about this
pandemic happens Trump gives a press
conference and he says I am suspending
travel for all non-us citizens and
permanent residents from Europe now
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
do but he didn't actually talk to the
Europeans about it beforehand he just
announced that they found out about on
TV so the next day the EU condemned at
the Trump administration condemned them
for making that policy that's insane I
mean could you imagine 2008 financial
crisis the Europeans condemning us for a
decision all that would have taken was a
leader of the United States in advance
getting on the [ __ ] phone with the
Brits and the French and the Germans and
the Italians saying look we've got these
problems you have this problem we let's
announce together that we're gonna
coordinate how we handle international
transit let's go and we'll all announce
it together we can even do it at a g7
meeting what do you think about that
because it'll show it'll build some
confidence right confidence building and
this is a skill it takes like an extra
like day own goals that kill me I
understand that us providing PPE and
tests to other countries we're not going
to be able to do that I get that but at
least take the geopolitical Hippocratic
oath do no harm and we have a President
of the United States that cannot help
but actively harm us position in the
world at a time when that is the
stupidest possible thing to do and it's
because he lacks expertise he does not
listen to advisors he is a massive
narcissist he can't get out of his own
way he doesn't care you so did not want
a big crisis under this president and
unfortunately we now have the biggest
crisis since World War two under this
president
[Music]
now when when you talk about trying to
address big things like climate change
multilaterally one of the things I said
on the campaign trail was hey if we
don't get our act together at some point
another country is just gonna start
geoengineering you know there's gonna
look up and say like wait a minute like
you know my sea levels are rising like
this is a massive problem maybe I should
just start launching sulfur dioxide
clouds into the atmosphere and obviously
that ends up affecting all of us and the
example I used is I was like a Pacific
island nation that's literally like
going underwater it's like you know and
so if they had the capacity to do
engineer would they have tried like
probably because it's literally like
that or you know your entire country
submerges and the problem with
geoengineering is that it's cheap yeah I
mean you're not talking about trillions
you're talking about single-digit
billions of dollars that would allow you
to throw enough into the atmosphere to
actually bring down the temperature now
doesn't help you with salinization and
all of the dead you know no life in in
the oceans doesn't actually help you
with the amount of carbon and the
atmosphere so if you stop doing it just
the whole thing blows up and there's no
good science on all the other
second-order effects nevermind the fact
that you're affecting everyone around
the world not just your own country but
if the choice is that or your nation
commits suicide if the choice is that or
50 million people trying to become
climate migrants but no one will take
them well I mean it would be
irresponsible for you not to spend the
few billion dollars wouldn't it so I
mean if all if we're telling these
people screw you we do not care about
you they have an obligation for their
own people to take matters into their
own hands and geopolitically in what I
call a g0 world not a g7 not a g20 but
an absence of leadership a g0 leaders
will take those decisions and that is
what is happening today in response to
coronavirus and it's what's going to
happen tomorrow with geoengineering if
we don't get our act to
they're on climate in a coordinated
fashion pretty soon well one thing I
will say about Joe having spent some
time with him how much time you spent
with Joey and I know you a little
I mean I've what two dumb meetings with
them and such yeah I figure he is well I
will have to do that at some point we'll
go in you know we'll do the world data
organization together with them that'll
be fun yeah that this this will happen I
will say that Joe has a very very deeply
embedded international list and global
has bent like he very much wants to
revive or restore like us global
leadership and rebuild alliances and
relationships that that seems to be very
much a natural impulse for him I
completely believe that I really do but
keep in mind so did Obama and and the
reason he couldn't do it is not because
his staff was incompetent it wasn't
because Obama wasn't smart it's not
because he doesn't understand things it
was because the rest of the world is a
lot harder to support that alignment
than it used to be the Europeans are
weaker the Russians are in decline they
blame us for it the Chinese are stronger
they're building competitive models but
also because a hell of a lot of
Americans are saying No Mas to this
stuff yeah you can't do anything unless
you have a president that's oriented in
that direction and Biden will certainly
be an improvement over Trump on that
stuff but that's I just don't think
that's enough I think we there are a lot
of a lot of additional lifting that
we're gonna require well you and I agree
too and what's one reason we I think we
get along is that we see the need for
institutions but we also recognize the
limitations particularly of the
institutions were set up in a world that
no longer exists I agree with you that
they're gonna be limitations to what the
next president can do globally even if
they do have the best of intentions you
know one of the natural human impulse is
to say that well there's got to be some
self aligning in this mess and one of
the the hopes I have is that we're going
to accelerate the problems but we might
accelerate some of the solutions - yeah
I mean I think that there are a lot of
things that are being sped up by this
and we've talked about a lot of the
geopolitical challenges the inequality
that's being sped up but I mean
telemedicine is being sped up
yeah remote work universal basic income
certainly the skies are clear
I mean we're polluting less though you
know and like the least positive way
possible because we're all stuck at home
yeah yeah but you know I mean one of the
happiest people I know is right now is
the former prime minister of Bhutan who
you know has is using this to pay more
attention to nature and meditate a
little bit more and you know those guys
don't really care how much their economy
grows every year but they care a lot
about whether they're healthy and happy
and seem functional in in their broader
community and III hope that a few months
at home forces those Americans who are
so incredibly fortunate compared to so
many around the world to ask ourselves
what really matters to us because if we
could vote for that we'd be a better
country yes that is the goal we have to
show people that we can vote for things
that are bigger and deeper than stock
market prices yeah we have to ask
ourselves how can so few people spend so
much time and so much effort pursuing
things that obviously do not help either
themselves or humanity yeah we can see
very clearly who the essential workers
are now you know yeah like it's not that
hedge fund manager Ian do you have
anything you're working on that you'd
like to promote g0 media is awesome
if anyone wants to hear more from this
genius man g0 media is the place to go
is there anything else you're working on
that you want to share yeah they should
sign up for the newsletter g0 Mediacom
you can do that's the easiest way to
follow what we're doing watch the TV
show g0 world I mean I'm working on a
book right now but it's it's a solid
year before it comes out so so it's too
early for that what's the book about
it's about what happens after this
global order it's what comes next oh my
gosh what happens that's look right now
yeah I mean I need that book like heck
man I'm gonna be cribbing from you in in
the days that come hopefully you know
from the White House we'll be in there
trying to heal the world to the extent
we can man I mean I'm seriously we've
been in this for a couple of months and
the country is not in good shape right
now and we know this is this is not
going to get easier over the next few
months this is
this year is gonna be so freakin hard
for so many people and I you just feel
it you just feel it I feel that we all
do feel it and it's material but it's
personal it's human it's like a journey
of the Spirit in many ways like I try
and remind myself every day of how
fortunate I am my family to the fact
that you know like everyone's healthy
but people are undergoing trials big and
small whether it's because your loved
one is dying or just you're trapped in
your home and you're dealing with
isolation on a personal level that
you've never dealt with before
yeah yeah that's true well Ian you and
I'll be on the other side you are a man
of genius intellect character vision and
I'm proud to consider your friend love
you man great to be with you man
love you too stay safe brother
[Music]
[Applause]